well how do you think gays for Gaza will
get on long term well the joke at the
moment is there aren't enough tall
buildings in Gaza to throw gays for Gaza
off
um
but these I mean these people are you
know I've said very often they're
they're part of the same phenomenon as
turkeys for Christmas and chickens for
KFC I mean I just I've fed up these in
Fringe idiot cases I mean they're so
mentally defective these people uh and
and Incredibly narcissistic you know I
can beer and also celebrate panis now
you [__] can't [__]
off
just you know I can both argue for
two-state solution and also celebrate
queerness and also not let myself down
no you can't no you can't you can't do
all those things at some point you got
to choose I've got a video to show you
show you this
video can
someone please explain to me what this
means what does reproductive Justice
Means free Palestine what does that even
mean like what does it mean I'm pretty
sure I'm not pretty sure abortions are
illegal in Palestine unless it's like
you know a super medical emergency and
the mother will die from what I
understand actually a lot of
Palestinians have to go to Israel to get
the abortions they want so what does
this mean yeah what it it's such a huge
sign there's five people holding this
thing it's
massive that's very good that's Danny
the other half of Ryan who wasn't there
the day that you that you came um voice
cast reproductive Justice Means free
Palestine what do you think can this is
just this is just incredibly ignorant
young people in America who have been
taught this weird
version of the world where all
oppressions Interlink and interlock and
you're either the majority or the
minority for minority rights and issues
or for majority rights and issues and
all minority rights and issues intersect
and overlap so that if you're queer
somehow you well no it's not even that
these ignoramuses who couldn't point to
the River Jordan if you showed it them
on a map um walk along the streets from
sh you know from The River To The Sea
Palestine will be free because I think
the Palestinians the under dogs in this
weird version where they've mapped
American racial well they've mapped a
very specific version of American racial
politics onto everything else in the
world it's the same thing who talk
people who talk about
colonizers I mean there's this language
of colonizers apartheid all this stuff
and they've just tried to map it
everywhere well I say everywhere
actually it's highly selectively highly
selectively I mean the people who are
talking about Israelis being
colonizers um when I saw that the other
day on the Streets of London I thought
yes if only there was a name for large
numbers of people who came from outside
to a
country and um if only we could identify
what they might be called in
Britain oh it would be immigrants
wouldn't it do you want to call
immigrants colonizers in Britain you
sure you want to follow this logical
conclusion that talk about indigenous
peoples oh okay great anywh you don't
want to apply that might there be a
country or cont say oh Europe where you
don't want to start talking about the
indigenous peoples I notice that people
don't but if you do want
to Welcome to
Hell so no all that is happening is a
very selective mapping of a particular
interpretation of the world that very
dumb people in America have tried to put
on certain selective other cases and it
doesn't work it just doesn't work but
may they never find out how much it
doesn't work may they never find
out um I I wish some Bliss in their
ignorance because if their ignorance
ever gets popped it will be as brutal a
day as Can Be
Imagined I've been thinking for a good
while about how hypocrisy is a
purpose-built tool for the internet to
use it's it's like catnip for the
Internet it's the thing because the
reason it's so purpose built it's like a
one of those Can you spot the difference
competitions on a touchscreen iPad this
is what's on the left this is what's on
the right and what you have is here's
something that someone once said or a
position that they used to hold and here
is what they hold now or here is what
they do in their real life or here is
whatever and it's kind of what you're
identifying here that you have a
worldview which is self-contradictory
you're just using different words for
one thing that is almost exactly the
same for another thing right and then
complaining about this one saying don't
look don't don't look over here at this
one yeah uh well I mean everyone is
inconsistent to to some extent and I
don't think by the way that I mean I
mean on hypocrisy or you know for
instance I can see a scenario where
somebody might say oh Douglas you're
hypocritical on this particular question
I might say well you know there are some
things I think are even more important
than not being a hypocrite such as I
don't know
surviving I the worst thing about him is
hypocrisy and there's a there's a weird
hypocrisy is is the easiest one to catch
people on is the truth of that correct
yes it's easiest one to spot yes um you
just and and they they do it as you say
on this is what this person said 20
years ago this is what they say now okay
again human being in growing up shocker
yes yeah um people are allowed to evolve
they change their minds they grow up be
rather boring to say the same thing and
think the same thing only for 70 years
um but yeah people find hypocrisy very
very easy to to see and it's about the
only Vice you can really catch somebody
on I think which is if you say one thing
publicly and do another thing privately
it's about the only one that people are
really confident on uh or most other
moral judgments For Better or Worse have
sort of ebbed away but people still are
able to judge uh hypocracy
um uh but I think I I mean I I think
there were worse things I I think not
standing up for your loved ones not
standing up for your country not
standing up for uh yourselves in the
face of horrible opposition
from within without probably worse than
hypocrisy I heard you say recently you
don't have to agree with everyone's
principle to respect the principle
they're sticking
to did I say that yeah sounds good yeah
it's nice okay I I didn't know I said
that but yeah you did uh but the reason
that I like that is I think it
shows
why The Bravery conversation or standing
up for something that you believe in is
something that is a at least then if
someone is prepared to stand up for
whatever their beliefs are that you can
assume they're telling the truth
especially if they pay a high price for
it it's one of the reasons why I have uh
a good amount of faith that Sam believes
the things that he says because why
would he not he pays an unbelievably
high price to continue to flip-flop from
One Tribe to another tribe to another
tribe I don't think it's an unbelievably
high price but a price let's say
relatively high price
yeah yeah I I I mean very early in some
people's careers or when people first
make it to public notice people say
things like you know do you really
believe what you say the answer to which
for most people is or ought to be well
why would I say it if I didn't believe
it uh there are people who obviously do
say stuff for LOLs or clicks or malary
purpose but at a certain point I mean
you you got to accept that the person
thinks what they think and you know
respect them for it or at least do them
the decency of believing that they mean
it and I think that even on people I
disagree with wildly I mean it's such a
boring argument that one some people use
it particularly on the left is like you
know I wonder if they actually even
believe it I think they don't I think
they're just doing it for money okay
well that's an easier way to try to
ignore them than actually trying to
contend with the possibility of what
they're saying is something they mean
and believe and trying to work out if
there's anything in it much easier to
say the person's only doing it because
they're paid or something in other news
this episode is brought to you by Maui
newie venison Maui Nei venison brings
the healthiest red meat on the planet
direct to your door not only is it the
most nutrient-dense meat on the planet
they're the only 100% stress-free wild
harvested venison that you can get
here's my super secret hack if you are
sick of buying meat that always goes off
put it in the freezer from Frozen salt
both sides of it put it in an air fryer
for 10 to 12 minutes each side and you
have a perfectly cooked steak from
Frozen that will never go off because
it's going from freezer to mouth in the
space of 25 minutes it's a complete Game
Changer all of the cuts are spectacular
and you can get them Frozen delivered to
your your door but their venison sticks
are my favorite while I've been on the
road you can get the healthiest red meat
on the planet delivered directly to your
door and get 20% off by going to the
link in the description below or heading
to Maui venison tocom slod wisdom and
using the code modern wisdom at checkout
that's M AI Nui venison docomo wisdom
and modern wisdom at checkout thank you
very much for tuning in if you enjoyed
that clip with Douglas you will love the
2hour long podcast episode which you can
watch right
here go
on